hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights of [ __ ]
boys I found the real guitar which only
leaves one item left for the last
character but at the same time I'm
having trouble because I don't have
enough to heal and apparently these guys
don't want me to heal up in combat more
than 600 unless I don't know chicas
heals I guess do good baby the way time
for one more shot one more delicious
gigantic shot so cheers everybody you
guys are the best oh oh oh oh for those
of you are playing at home okay although
I need to like I don't know why toy
bonnie's levelling so slowly in
comparison to everyone else but you know
I got the enema that I needed here so
only I need left is Foxy's ultimate
weapon besides of course the dragon
dildo which I know is the thing in here
and people are gonna really really
really really want me to get that
and also the puppet I forgot about the
puppet so I assume that it has something
to do with like the the the minigames in
the other room there which must mean
there's got to be like something else
there [ __ ] you guys oh come on you guys
can't even touch me ah that's got too
much defense no puppet man this illegal
okay so there's got to be some way to
get that but until I know that way I
just got to keep fighting cameras so I'm
just gonna keep doing that because fire
I got nothing else to do why not okay
there's a camera needs one of these
rooms I believe so I just destroy them
yes please engage the camera I know I
know it's it's incredible I'm so good at
what I do I still don't know what that's
all about but wait okay was Bonnie skill
grab-bag okay Bonnie only does through
tech attacks
so there's got to be some other way to
do this whoa oh nice done it done
Paul this is easy this is get out this
was like that was a level three camera I
just annihilated awesome spread bomb I
don't know what that is I thought a name
I said okay so toy Bonnie and toy chica
are both skill-based like their attacks
are only really like the the the the
tech points that they need so I remember
there was an item that could upgrade
tech points but okay let's not go here
yet because this is way too but I
probably am gonna be able to be oh this
is level two really easy all right fine
then fine by me
you're gonna tell me twice oh man I
heard so bad okay twenty Bonnie's level
16 about to have time toy Bonnie okay so
I'm like clearing through all of these
sons of [ __ ] easily but I do need
more items so it handled my dog I know I
know okay so I guess I need large pizzas
mostly just it's not cost-efficient like
I need medium pizzas for out of combat
but even so it's like it's really not
efficient
okay medium sodas large sodas I have
plenty of these this is like not enough
okay doughnuts but not necessarily what
I need but I guess there's no harm in
having them okay Gloria saying to me I
know I know I know okay so there's got
to be like okay oh come on
thank you don't have time for you I
gotta beat this guy before the puppet
becomes the problem oh come on it was
gonna be a clean sweep or not because
that didn't work anyway man they do no
damage to me like my defenses are just
way way too high
there we go good job mango holy [ __ ] you
didn't even have your ultimate weapon oh
that was a critical eye token everybody
everybody I'm an idiot okay sex toy
voucher a sex toy voucher why did I need
another sex toy voucher what is that a
thing I needed this doesn't make any
sense you just you alone fine
die die if you want to die so badly
thank you I don't understand it whatever
my problem okay so it's gonna be good to
puppet damn I'm not seeing anything out
of the ordinary like how many other how
many other like cameras could there
possibly be
I got like most of them what was that
something happen what happened what
happened what happened something Aven
oh what's that what is it assembly
Keystone what what is that a mystical
Jim Mickle touches learn the combo skill
okay cool
why was that a thing I don't understand
what that was why was that a thing well
I guess mango learned your ultimate
skill but okay so do I have to somehow
go back to the places where I found
something I don't know what it wants for
me god damn it's get away god damn it
[ __ ] a dog you can't touch me what's the
point guy my hand is literally cramping
up like I don't know why it's getting
really bad okay so if that was that like
there were chests that we're appearing
is there another thing in here oh there
is holy [ __ ] avian Keystone okay cool
okay cool I guess
what's that all mean I don't understand
anything that's happening right now okay
whatever whatever
ain't no problem it is what it is it is
what it got damn it
holy [ __ ] wait did I get an ultimate
item for me yet I don't know if I did oh
[ __ ] you guys are tough hold [ __ ] I
didn't realize sorry sorry sorry
oh you don't do a lot of damage anyway
okay it's fine Jesus just kill one of a
bear we go kill kill kill kill please
kill kill kill kill kill kill kill kill
kill kill kill kill
okay good you're good that was easy I
don't know I was so worried about that
god damn it give me a goddamn ultimate
items that's all I want is it really so
hard to give me the ultimate items okay
so I guess I could farm in there for the
items that I need I don't think there's
gonna be anything in here is there I
already got the chest from there it's
something spawned here
no just you goddamn thing it's like I
don't understand what you are all about
okay so if I got that in there [ __ ] just
get out that way okay so I got the thing
in here no I did okay yes yes absolutely
it's a camera [ __ ] okay got that
one Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
I don't know why Freddie's like my main
point of damage because I know that
Bonnie can do a lot of damage but
without technical Ani doesn't do much
easy-peasy
Donna died okay that's bad but it still
leaves a lot of unanswered questions
like what am i doing why am i doing it
what what is the purpose of what I'm
doing right now like I understand what
the purpose is just total [ __ ] and
no real sense out of it but like what is
my objective besides killing cameras
there's got to be something hidden
because I know like I understand that I
kill cameras yes I beat the game
whatever Donna done but what I want to
know is like there's got to be something
else to it
riot that's got to be it's got to be
something else to it okay whatever I
need to get back to the public before I
do anything else it's gotta be something
I like I hate missing out on something
and I hate the idea that people would be
watching this a belay no you daft prat
you didn't do dingle donger and
dagger I know I didn't do double dagger
but come on I'm not a double Dan your
kind of guy like I'm not ready for that
yeah okay so all right so I don't know I
don't know I guess I guess just keep
killing cameras I guess god damn it if
that could stop that'd be lovely so I
guess I guess there's two cameras in the
vents
there's definitely cameras in the vents
that I can get okay so let me just go
get those that I'll be good I guess
Boop okay please kill this son of a
[ __ ] here yes absolutely engage that
camera [ __ ]
okay so engage you you're gonna do that
we're gonna like whale on this guy first
okay hey what skill do you have grab bag
pulls out a random item I don't know
what that is but no matter I'll try
because people got really mad at me when
I didn't even try oh [ __ ] okay maybe
this was a horrible mistake
okay just feel smoke don't leave don't
do anything actually significant just
dude lay down and die there we go
ah [ __ ] I thought that was gonna be a
problem for a second there I still don't
know what that music is all about why
it's so very Japanese but hey I'm
complaining so long as it's royalty-free
I guess I'm gonna be totally okay with
it come on come on oh come on
there we go thank you so that's another
one down I [ __ ] did it eat my [ __ ]
still don't know why I'm trying to do
that but it is what it is it's old cake
you medium pizzas you you you you you
you you you alright meme soda you you
you okay
save goddamn there's like so many little
micromanage me micromanaging things that
I need to do to make sure that my game
experience isn't completely [ __ ] over
by [ __ ] okay so because the only
other one is to get the I have enough
time I can get the I can get the other
one I'm pretty sure I can get the whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa no one say anything
about that what the [ __ ] when did wither
jjigae get here I don't know if I'm
ready for wither chika I'm not gonna do
that
oh [ __ ] this hard and let me say before
I do this this might be a long fight or
something
are we're gonna give you all we got
[ __ ] gotta get it out high
chance of missing I like that idea
[ __ ]
goddamn it goddamn it oh come on oh it's
not going well
oh [ __ ] I am dead in the water
status Bob come on huh [ __ ] god damn it
manga
okay it leases manga bangles not all
that bad the enemy's side was blinded
good cool come on not toy Freddy that's
my main hitter man okay there we go
still hit still hit still it yes okay
got it got it got it
alright cool this is going well for me
I'm having a lot of fun I don't know if
you
but I'm having a lot of fun play this
game I don't know mr. Bouchard but I'm
having a ton of fun right now
goddamn but skip it's cool like it
shouldn't be this cool but it's really
cool I [ __ ] dead eat my stick okay so
that was that was all of them so this
withered chica in here so that means
that I could come back and fight with
the chica but that doesn't mean the
withered chica gives me an ability like
why is withered chica there that doesn't
make much sense Hobbit no popping man
that's illegal oh shut up
no one cares alright so now I need to
resurrect my dude you need better pizza
man there's got to be a better piece why
is it why it's like Balloon Boy so
limited here whoa what what I got a sex
toy what is why why do I have a sex toy
I thought I already had a sex toy okay
so I have two sex toys was the point why
do I have that you know what whatever
fine whatever I got the hiccups bad oh
not ready for this oh [ __ ] I guess
somebody's will try to fight with her
Bonnie hey you [ __ ] give me
experience you [ __ ]
give me one don't give me what I need oh
[ __ ] I got Vegas oh god damn it
please stop aah
get out of my way a little bit for you I
got [ __ ] to do Oh God okay so withered
Bonnie let me go fight with her buddy or
wither [ __ ] god damn it okay how about
no hey oh [ __ ]
but gosh damn it uh what god damn it oh
god stop oh boy again with the Japanese
music is just like all of your
royalty-free goddamn to stop yes
stop I mean you're not out healing the
damage that I'm doing but still like
stop wait a bit of spread Bob that
doesn't sound good
oh come on oh [ __ ] I should have upped
my skill before I did this
oh come on oh [ __ ] hello boy this is a
this is a goddamn Zig oh [ __ ]
sass Bob cut stop it he pieces you
[ __ ] yeah I blinded him good [ __ ]
Oh God at least he's blind and now he's
poison
oh he's got damn hiccups too good to be
the Chesapeake what the [ __ ] am i doing
[ __ ] love wizard chica I got a fight
here
oh they goddamn place [ __ ] oh my god oh
[ __ ] oh god damn it out fro da Freddie
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah I hope he stays I've
long enough to do something stop it with
your hot their pizzas [ __ ] stop oh [ __ ]
I don't even know what I'm doing it more
like not paying attention not oh [ __ ]
stop it I need like to do thing is why
aren't you dead yet but I better hope
this works god damn it
[ __ ] oh stop it with the pizzas
[Music]
[Laughter]
what what what how that work how do I
get what the [ __ ] it doesn't I need to
get to the puppet before her my [ __ ]
gets [ __ ] up what I didn't know he was
gonna join my part oh my god oh [ __ ]
thank you oh [ __ ] oh God I need more
cakes oh [ __ ]
God biess hiccup Scott dammit huh [ __ ]
Stevie stop I can't handle this I'm not
gonna be able to do this if this keeps
bugging up like this oh [ __ ] [ __ ] duck
not doing well if I know I be withered
foxy why isn't that a thing that's
happening [ __ ] no God very good very
good
Oh God
stop it please I can't take any more oh
boy this is not a good F is here for me
okay
so I gotta admit I gotta imagine that
the other withered things are here so
talk I think they out of here somewhere
so I gotta find him they're not the
bathroom I take the bathroom okay so the
other one's gonna be ready somewhere
Blue Boy yeah hello wizard fly see wait
that's probably gonna be a harder fight
right but I got like no I already beat
you once what I did not pull I didn't up
my coffee I didn't up my steez god damn
oh I didn't why didn't i up my steez oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
Santa's Bob and wither chigi Jesus oh my
god it's the same thing
ah man Huda know that I would have liked
a [ __ ] goddamnit
you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll let it die from
this one oh is not gonna go well oh man
oh god stop it please God that it's like
it does nothing now and everyone's gonna
do that's [ __ ] spread bombs could
these hiccups please dear God
stop I can't do it oh man withered foxy
his toughest [ __ ]
ah baby I like cuz they're like withered
freddy is that a fig withered Bonnie Oh
with her body you we know it was going
to the other game too good I'm gonna
[ __ ] your STIs I didn't heal up by
Steve's I didn't put my goddamn STIs in
order [ __ ] oh [ __ ] Oh try that well
these hiccups would stop it be
phenomenal withered body why why oh god
oh god these hiccups aren't stopping
[ __ ] you why Freddy God screw you oh man
this is done oh man is that good [ __ ] oh
my god holy [ __ ] okay we're still in
this game
what's the other game oh my God we're
not in the game are we oh [ __ ]
Oh God he tried back up bash on me he
tried to think that every old want to be
to do but I didn't do he's a [ __ ]
idiot
[ __ ] so we're like like why am i able to
get the ultimate thing for like chica
and whatnot but I'm not able to get what
I need for the other things that me
Kenny says I don't even know god you
[ __ ] hiccups need to stop Jesus not a
spread Bob [ __ ] maybe you would die
that'd be awesome
that would be so cool right now Margot
I'm dead I'm dead aren't I oh [ __ ] god
damn it these [ __ ] hiccups they make
me seem more drunk than I really am but
I'm not I've got that drug the [ __ ]
hang-ups Jesus Christ I got a log trade
of peeps do I need to like equip them
with [ __ ] - I probably do I probably
should do that but goddamn if these
hiccups will just [ __ ] stop I would
be greatly appreciated [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
although I'm gonna end this episode here
because I can't I can't do anything else
jeez I'm like pair paralyzed with
hiccups so thank you everybody so much
for watching check out the other cool
videos that I've done in the description
below thank you all so much for being
here
yeah as always I'll see you in the next
week
[Music]
I do